hey people welcome to the reuben report
i'm the human filibuster dave rubin and
i've got vanessa gomez and whitney
mixter with me we got a ton of great
stories for you we're in the midst of a
24-hour period right now where there is
more speaking than probably has ever
been done in the history of humanity uh
literally just like five minutes ago ted
cruz ended his like 21 hour filibuster
that's a lot of talking even for a
politician and then over in new york at
the united nations uh which i also refer
to lovingly as the legion of doom uh
they've been having the uh the general
assembly and a lot of a lot of talking
not much action a lot of talking so
we're gonna get to all that and plenty
more including a diet fries from uh
burger king but let's start with the
general assembly in new york this is
every year everybody gets together they
put on their suits they pretend they
like each other and they give big
speeches which are going to be going on
all week
this really is all right now at least
about iran and their new president
rouhani and president obama is trying to
uh be buddy buddy with them and uh let's
take a listen in the near term america's
diplomatic efforts
will focus on two particular issues
iran's pursuit of nuclear weapons
and the arab-israeli conflict
while these issues are not the cause of
all the region's problems
they have been a major source of
instability for far too long and
resolving them can help serve as a
foundation for a broader peace
the united states and iran have been
isolated from one another since the
islamic revolution of 1979.
this trust has deep roots
iranians have long complained of a
history of u.s interference in their
affairs
and of america's role in overthrowing an
iranian government during the cold war
on the other hand americans see an
iranian government that has declared the
united states an enemy
and directly or through proxies taken
american hostages killed u.s troops and
civilians
and threatened our ally israel with
destruction okay so
first off i just want to note that i
feel like obama had just the right
amount of gray in his hair for that you
know they adjust his gray depending on
how serious they want him to be i feel
like they really nailed it with that one
uh so rowani is the new president
they're calling him a moderate they're
saying he's on a charm offensive right
now
he also is not denying the holocaust
like ahmadinejad he just says he's not a
historian so i guess that's progress
somehow uh what what do you guys make of
this uh
the overture is going on here this
little dance you know they didn't meet
they said they were going to maybe meet
at a lunch but then it turned out there
was wine at the lunch so rouhani didn't
want to go to a place where alcohol was
being served but what do you think of
this whole idea of putting on a suit and
everybody coming and at least talking
that does seem like maybe that's a
little bit of progress right
i mean i think it's it's it's the united
states way of just being nice i think
there should be like a guy next to obama
being like look here's the thing you
guys are shady as [ __ ] we know it
everybody knows it that's just what we
know but we can't be the bad guy and
come in there and just you know because
we have a bad reputation to just come in
and storm and say you got to change
everything so we're like you know what
we don't want to change your operation
we don't we don't want to mess with you
we just don't want you having
weapons of mass destruction and killing
everybody so we're just gonna play nice
and then you know is when i was a kid it
was like don't start nothing won't be
nothing you know what i mean like it was
like you know as long as you go
but when you start something we're gonna
end it and it's not gonna be good so
um i mean that would be a good name for
a phone
i mean
listen they have proven over and over
again that every treaty they go into
they they breach in some way or whatever
i mean not just to us and obama pointed
that out he's like look it's not even
just you know our beef it's like
everybody's beef
and you're picking on you know islam and
that's you know that's a sore spot for
us too so
i think it's just our nicety way of not
just barging in as we maybe would before
like look we're trying to do this civil
we're trying to do this peacefully we're
trying to you know i think it's more of
like a front like that so that when we
do eventually go in bartending when we
run and it's like yeah when we're
rolling hard like hey you brought it you
know so is that really what's going on
because it does seem good to me on its
face it seems good we're talking again
maybe it seems good i mean at face value
there's so many aspects of government
can seem great i think though going
along with what you were saying i think
that it would
give added uh you know value if they
played the theme song from colors in the
background
you know and like yeah there's like you
know you could get like hood with it
come on let's call it what it is here
like you know i think obama first of all
the way he delivers his speeches in
general i always wait for that pause i
feel like i'm like getting lulled to
sleep like by this like george clooney
of a president yeah well didn't this
speech seem particularly pausy i think
he was very slow in this it's very and
there's like a pause before he says
1979.
what's going to happen
it pans to
john kerry who's actually sitting there
like this like watching him like
like with like a downturned
face well he can't really move his face
at this point so that's not necessarily
indicative of what obama is yeah but you
know i think
his approach is very like
like you said like very homey approach
very laissez faire like you know what
let's just call it even
screw it you know i think you did your
fair share we did our fair share let's
just you know truce homie like let's do
this but that's what i mean by progress
because we never had an american
president that went to the united
nations it was like you guys have some
valid reasons for hating us you know we
had bush before this and it was nothing
was ever oh we just barged yeah that's
what i mean
so the idea of talking even though they
didn't do the handshake and that's
obviously not going to happen this week
it basically seems pretty pretty good
right like do you think there's any you
know a lot of republicans are saying
well this is bad because then you know
we're well
not talking right really thought about
it that's close enough
it's like in a relationship you're like
dude i gave you the benefit of the doubt
you know what i mean like you you're
using it just so later down the line
because you know you're going to end up
later down the line that you can use
that and pull out that card and be like
remember we wanted to talk it out okay
we'll talk it's over welcome to the
missiles and whatever yeah so do you
guys both think that this is that that's
really what's going on here this is just
the nice talk before ultimately
something has to be i mean based on
history or will it be done yeah i mean
it's an idealistic approach i mean
in reality it's an idealistic approach
we have to see how things pan out with
you know
who who sticks to their word longer who
it's like a waiting game you know it's a
chess game that's literally what's
happening here yeah so it's like you
know whoever acts first it's gonna it's
gonna come to a head yeah well i do have
to say i've been very hard on obama
lately especially with all the serious
stuff but i do think the talking is sort
of good even if at the end it just means
that the smackdown it's much more civil
to do it that way or to at least look or
appear as though we're trying to go the
peaceful route first
and then you know that second yeah we're
americans it's all about appearance here
apparently uh but yeah so the whole real
issue uh at the u.n right now is that
this unveiling of the new president uh
of iran uh rouhani and they're calling
it the charm offensive and he's sitting
down with american media and uh he sat
down with uh christian amanpour we're
going to get to her in just a moment but
i want to show you just a little bit of
the beginning of their interview
hello mr president
nice to see you salaam alaikum nice to
see you again exactly please
welcome to cnn thank you for doing this
for us i want to ask you what it feels
like to be
what some people have called the it man
of this unga
highly anticipated you seem to be the
focus of attention and unusually for
iranian presidents people are looking at
you with some at least cautious optimism
what does it feel like to be in this
position kaplan care
before responding to your question
i'd like to actually extend my greetings
to the people of america who are very
dear and near to the hearts of the
iranian people and to wish them a good
time and good times ahead
he's wishing them a good time and good
times ahead i'm pretty sure he's talking
about the sitcom um
okay so this is very typical of what
amanpour does she cozies up to all these
people and then they say things that are
you know oh it's a good we're gonna have
a good time everything's great meanwhile
you know they don't have facebook and
twitter they had it for like a day last
week in iran and then it was taken away
you know gay people are still being put
to death all kinds of horrible stuff
that everybody knows about but they use
our media uh to make themselves feel
better and appear better
is it nuts that we let our western media
we're free here so we let everyone talk
but is it a little nuts that we let
everybody talk to us in this in this
fashion i mean
everyone or i i think she does a specif
a specifically good job at really like
nudging that like giving a
under-the-table tug to all these these
people that she interviews you know
we're gonna get to that
i mean
it's literally like i feel like she's
sitting down and it should be like e
entertainment news in the background
she's like interviewing him on like the
latest movie that he's put out like you
you look great you're doing a great job
how are the kids you know it's like no
you're the man of them yeah you're the
man you were great on that red carpet
yeah exactly that's what it is and
that's why he has the liberty he he
should feel comfortable being like i'd
like to just take a minute and just talk
about
hey everyone hope you're having a good
time looking good kiss some babies and
uh you know it's like it's be it
especially in this situation it's just
kind of
narrowed down to a ridiculous state yeah
it's not even dealing with issues like
you're avoiding any serious all right
well before we bring that point really
home what do you think about them using
the western media because we do have
free media here so
they should be able to sword yeah i
think absolutely we should have it by
all you know means i i'm really for
rights and forward you know everyone
should have a voice and we should hear
all sides and all of that unfortunately
their her voice and their voice is is
part of the voices that have to be heard
so um but to your fact when he's like
chilling and relax and whatever i mean
if you if you're really you know you're
the president of iran like you're a huge
figure and you're sitting down with a
serious journalist who's gonna be asking
you hard-hitting questions yeah wouldn't
you be a little nervous wouldn't you be
sweating a little bit like sweating like
paula deen at the vt awards just just a
bead of sweat you know just something
like a little simmer i mean the fact
that they're so relaxed it's like they
know that it's a [ __ ] right well he
didn't he didn't sweat in that interview
but he did sweat at the united nations
yeah that's good at least but okay so
the reason i wanted to bring that clip
up and really focus on christian
amanpour is because she does have a
history of interviewing these people
pushing their propaganda and then
talking about it after even which is
even more furthering their ideas so this
is two years ago remember muhammad morsi
he was the muslim brotherhood leader who
then was voted in democratically but
everyone knew he wasn't going to bring
democracy and then he got deposed and
now he's in jail in egypt right now not
a good guy did not do any of the things
he said he was going to do but here she
is interviewing him right before he was
voted in
the slogan has come back again and there
are people who are concerned that a
muslim brotherhood which wins the
presidency and dominates the parliament
could introduce a fundamentalist
theocracy and islamic theocracy what do
you say to that
the egyptian people are freely making
their choice now and they are the ones
who chose the parliament we are talking
about elections and democracy if the
egyptian people have chosen their
leaders
then there won't be any room for worry
we want to transform from a president of
the institution to an institution of the
presidency
to an executive branch that represents
the people's true will and implements
their public
okay so there's literally not a word of
truth there that the people's will which
then he defied for a year and and made
democracy much worse and cracked down on
freedom of speech and all that stuff and
she just gives them a forum for this is
this
i mean we're going to talk a little more
about the media later but should we
expect more from our media you know why
why doesn't she lose credibility after
doing an interview like that and then
she does the rounding interview two
years later and everyone thinks that's
great and he's telling the truth
i mean
i i honestly don't i
there is no answer for that i can't
figure that out at all explain what a
cnn is exactly
thinking exactly it's like i have no
idea what she's thinking it's to me it
seems like she's just um
not doing her job like she's literally
just saying like reading facts about the
person and being like well i have no
analytical standpoint from this at all
i'm just gonna read these facts back to
you and you just affirm what you think
you know and
and the problem is it's like god in that
interview i remember when that first
came out but it's like hearing her say
so you're saying that women will have
rights and he goes on to
to say uh you know he yes women will
refers to things in a he he he he and at
which point if i was the reporter i
would you know question that you know if
you're
i just directly ask you asked you
something about women and you're
referring to them in a he standpoint
like women don't even exist but she goes
on to just completely smooth everything
over yeah i don't know and and honestly
it takes i love i generally like sienna
and i think it takes away credibility
like you know of
this
reporting quality if you will
sorry i totally agree i mean take it
away i think she goes along with it
because i think it's you know the
opportunity to sit down with you know
huge people and i think
you know
these people
are cool with sitting down with a
journalist that they know is not gonna
it's not gonna you know give them the
hard time um if you see all her
interviews they're not really interviews
to me an interview is you ask someone a
question they respond and you
either affirm that or maybe you're like
wait a minute stop you know she doesn't
really do back and forth it's kind of
like ask a question whatever you say
that's cool all right next question yeah
you know it's like that's not an
interview to me you know and so i think
that's what it is and it unfortunately
essentially turns out to be just
literally that a platform for them to
just come and say hey everything i mean
we saw how fantastic that turned out
right exactly you know so then why do
why don't people talk about it i don't
think i'm that much of a genius that i
was i mean i remembered watching that
clip two years ago and then i saw the
rouhani one and i was like i gotta show
these things back-to-back why doesn't
the media do it is it really just
because they want to keep getting i'm
obviously not interviewing rouhani and
he probably wouldn't sit down with him
but is it just because they just want to
be like well i mean it's like the white
house correspondents dinner like you
want to cozy up to the president and you
want to get the interview i mean you
have to think like in a sense you know
he's not sitting down with everyone you
know he's sitting down with her and it
probably is like you said he feels
comfortable so maybe it's that that
they're providing you with the
information that they're laying out on
the table and then you can take that and
either take it at face value or you can
read in between the lines as
as do the smart people of this panel
you know i love how if you watch the
clip which you can watch the whole thing
on on youtube she asked them again about
the holocaust which of course
ahmadinejad had denied and he says well
i'm not a historian
which
like and then she just she does exactly
what you said which is instead of
following up and saying well it's not
about whether you're historian they're
they're a historical it's like standing
in the rain and being like well i'm not
a meteorologist but uh you know it's
like right like it's not like are you
really conceding that much by saying
that the holocaust happened like is that
that much of a concession like
bad stuff can happen and it can happen
on both sides okay just craziness uh
speaking of more craziness so i just
mentioned it earlier the ted cruz
filibuster in the senate just ended i
think it went around 21 hours but since
it just ended i don't have the exact
number on me at this moment now
interestingly he was filibustering a
republican passed bill in the house that
was going to defund obamacare so he's a
republican filibustering a
republican-led bill
nothing will come of this obamacare
obviously is going through this is the
president's signature
thing in his entire
his legacy will basically be based in
this so nothing is going to happen with
it um but let's let's watch a little bit
of ted this is 21 hours of talking this
was about i think 10 hours in he also i
will i will credit my father he invented
this wasn't for the restaurant but he
did it anyway he invented green eggs and
ham
he did it two ways one the easy way is
he'd put green green food coloring in
eggs
chop up ham in it and as a kid green
eggs and ham was my favorite book when i
was a little boy
and so he would make me green eggs and
how you can actually do it the food
coloring is a little bit cheating
but if you actually take something like
spinach and mix it into the eggs the
eggs turn green okay before i
directly address that i did do a little
research on this obviously green eggs
and ham was uh written by dr seuss and
according to my research he's not even a
doctor so
i don't know who he's quoting when he's
really doing this about obamacare that
was a terrible joke
it's just really terrible um okay so
there were 21 hours of this
that was the in a way that ended up
being like the least of the crazy things
that were going on he started making all
these star wars comparisons that i liked
actually um
what what is the purpose of this you
know at least when rand paul did the
anti-drone thing everyone seemed to back
him and there was this idea that you
can't have a drone showing up and
blowing you up when you walk out at 7-11
or something but this became more of a
mockery is this just purely like him
going for 2016 like i need to boost my
profile i'm gonna talk for 21 straight
hours i think he did it for the bragging
rights hashtag filibuster master
um i mean look if he was reading you
know 50 shades of grey i might have
tuned in but um since he didn't i feel
like
just watching the little clips that i
did it was like i'm listening to his
therapy session out loud so maybe that's
why he did it i mean you hear yourself
talk for that long it's like you're just
he's like discovering things he's like
although we that was kind of cheating
with the yeah with the green thing maybe
with the spin it's like okay you know
whatever but yeah i absolutely think he
did it for
to say that he did it yeah because there
really was no reason so before we get
too glib about it if he really believes
that somehow giving universal health
care is going to destroy the country
because so many countries in the in the
past have been destroyed by health care
right like that's like everyone knows
that obviously oh yeah um
if he really believes it then he did do
the right thing and we should try to
give him a pass what do you think i mean
first of all i would like to go back and
say yes i think he did it for the um
bragging rights i think that there's
some like it's like some southern
barbecue house where they have like can
you eat this 25 pound burger you put
your picture up right like there's like
wendy davis and him you know like
there's like all pictures of politicians
who have successfully done it and how
many hours
yeah exactly but the the frustrating
point like part here is that on capitol
hill
you don't have it's incredibly liberal
on what you can what the technical terms
are of what you can talk about yeah
wendy davis got ousted at the 11th hour
for slightly getting off topic he's here
talking about nightmare on elm street
answering questions about you know horse
hair combs or whatever the hell and and
it's it's to me it's it's creating a
mockery out of the overall thing that
he's standing for you know yeah it
doesn't have it it's not a impressive
point to me that he can stand for 21
hours and talk yeah also i'm not sure if
people quite understand this point which
i've been tweeting a lot about that you
know the senate and congress they have
special health care that no one else has
access to already so this is a man who
has specialized healthcare filibustering
and trying to stop the rest of regular
people of getting universal healthcare
so the irony somehow the irony i mean
also the fact that he's standing there
and he's talking about how he's
representing the general public and
that's his goal to be the people's voice
his issues that he stands on completely
go against the popular opinion on on gun
control on a couple of different things
well there is that texas thing so it's
like he's representing texas
and those are the only people in the
country
you know i don't know i just think that
he's just completely
bass ackwards and everything but yeah is
that what politics is about though i
feel like this is kind of a mirror to
the obama speech it's like
he genuinely is against it and he thinks
that it's going to fail and that it's
going to be you know the demise of the
country so he wants to be able to say
for the record people do you remember
that i went on a field but you know what
i mean right so it's just like obama
being like hey man i put my hand out to
shake it you didn't show up does that
okay so i've been thinking about this a
lot does that make you guys think that
you know i talk about this stuff every
week and that's what all these news
networks are doing but that really it's
just this big charade it's this big you
know house of cards uh if you watch the
show you know it's all this backwards uh
back deal stuff where everyone's just
covering their ass constantly right yeah
in a country that where he can
legitimately read green eggs and him the
whole book yeah you know and everybody's
okay with it apparently it's just like i
mean
other countries with universal
healthcare are just looking at us
laughing like what is this yeah and
rightfully so apparently yeah one thing
i was sort of fascinated with this is
that the media coverage of this was a
little bizarre because fox obviously who
likes ted cruz they were showing a lot
of it cnn at one point had him in the
little box with no sound you know while
they show something else and msnbc was
actually showing uh video of why it's
ridiculous what he's doing which i guess
is all standard stuff and a perfect
segue for the next segment because uh
believe it or not the media they did
want war with syria uh and pretty uh
pretty intensely and over the topley a
new pew study found that all cable news
channels uh were more in favor of war
with syria than not going to war and
that includes the newest cable channel
uh the cable news channel al jazeera
which had promised a different take and
that they were going to give us you know
because we're so controlled here by the
media they were going to give us
something else turns out not exactly uh
let's look at some of the numbers on
this okay so
this is really kind of incredible and it
shows you how partisan everything has
become msnbc 64
of their messages about the war were
pro-war now at the same point they also
had the highest number of mentions that
were anti-war so they tried to balance
themselves out a bit uh but as you can
see fox was at 45 and then 20 against uh
we got a lot of there's a lot of numbers
there the the base point is as you can
see everything on the blue on the left
is higher all the pro war messages were
higher than the red ones uh so that just
gives you if you if you don't want to
break down the numbers with us there you
get the sense with colors pretty good um
should this not surprise us because the
media always wants to go to war because
that's when people watch
the news i guess it says in the article
that all the polls say that we don't
want to we just came from war like can
we get a second take a breather like
holy crap you know um i think that
i think they all i mean this may be is a
conspiracy theory but i feel like they
all have
a in a combined interest whether they're
liberal or conservative or whatever box
you want to put al jazeera in um
i think they're all after money and i
think war creates revenue for people and
i think that that's ultimately like it's
in their it's in certain people's best
interest to go to war even though it's
not good for the country i think other
people have there
right so isn't the msnbc example perfect
example of if this was bush wanting to
go to war obviously msnbc wouldn't have
been pro-war so it just shows you
they're all picking a side with their
guys so fox was against this war because
they don't like obama i mean this is
this is psych 101 right it's definitely
no shock though i mean people tune in
when there's a disaster when there's war
like that's when they're glued to the
tvs i mean think about when the trade
centers went down anything like that i
mean you become immersed in these
stories you know and so they want to
push for it and i think with ms nbc i
think what's happening there is that you
know that is they're kind of
targeting their demographic that's
watching it in terms of like that's
their main story i think fox has like
other stories they tackle on them
because their demographic might also be
more simpler in other
sects of things you know and
that was my pc way of putting things
um you know and i think that's why they
they talk about it more because even
i mean democrats want to hear about it
because they want to be like you know
kind of stand behind we're not going to
worry about you know this and that but
um
now i think it's absolutely no shocker i
mean people if you look at local news
they talk about car crashes murders and
you rarely hear about something that's
positive happening in the world it's a
shocker and it's about five seconds long
so yeah so is the fascinating part of
this that al jazeera did uh the same
basically the same sort of pro-war
messaging that the other three did
because people thought they were going
to come in and give us somehow more of a
balanced approach or something more
pro-arab so to speak but you know
they're based in uh qatar which has
obviously ties to saudi arabia saudi
arabia was offering for us
to pay for us to go to war so is it sort
of just this big it's just this big mess
of there's money is it like keeping up
with the jones is like i mean really is
it like news channels have to keep up
with what other news channels are doing
because there's obviously some type of
you know recipe for success people are
tuning in so if one station doesn't do
it to a certain level are people going
to just go to the next one yeah i guess
it's a little bit of just sort of like a
rally and cry like if everyone's like
let's go to war let's go to war there's
not that much excitement and let's not
go to war like how much programming
yeah like to target
it's like reality television you don't
tune in to see the girls like all get
along like you look amazing you look
amazing
you tune in for the part where you're
like you look amazing you look at me and
the interview they're like that [ __ ]
i can't believe this [ __ ] you know so
it's like obviously they're you know the
ratings are more for for the tension and
and and all of that and
we like to tune in to see things like
that versus like nice good stories
unfortunately yeah i cannot believe this
but the media is slightly less hated
this year than they were last year
that's right
44
of uh respondents in a new gallup poll
say that they have a great deal or a
fair amount of trust and confidence in
mass media that's actually identical to
2011 but it's up slightly four points
from 40
in 2012. i'm sort of shocked by this
because the more we have social media
the more we see all the constant errors
every time something's breaking on cnn
they make 10 different errors and they
retract it and people take away tweets
and now you know i mean every time
something happens there's a well oh
that's source or we got that one wrong
fox does it all the time too
let's take a look at uh the graph here
so you can see it's uh it's peaking up
just it looks a little on its way up at
the end there just a tiny bit and we're
only talking about four points but that
is something you'd think it maybe would
be dumping 20 points uh and the biggest
jump interestingly is uh in republicans
and uh independents that are trusting
the media yes because i don't understand
it's like the media
the media is reporting that we're more
trusted says the media you know it's
like it's like me being like according
to whitney mixture whitney is thinner
and smarter than last year
says i you know it's like it's like i
don't understand what who's where is
this coming from that was a good time
for you to touch your eyes
reporting live yes it's true i am
smarter than last year
no but and also
where is anybody also reporting on
whether or not they trust polls
more right
because also who gets you know i got a
call for the first time in my life this
week i got a call from quinnipiac that's
a college in connecticut that does they
do the big ones all right you're from
connecticut right yeah have you ever
been to the polling station over at
quinnipiac oh yes absolutely i spent my
summers there
i didn't even know well i got a call
from them this week and they said we
want to know uh you know if you'd be
involved in this poll and i was excited
because i was like i never got i wanted
no it was something well i don't know
what it was because i said well how long
is it going to take and they said about
12 minutes and i was like i don't have
time for that but even think about that
if who has time for a 12-minute poll so
the people you're getting in the polls
already are a group of people that i
guess just have a lot of time
that means people call them they're like
do you have 12 minutes oh yeah i got
time do you trust the media sure
like you're just looking for someone to
say
yeah exactly watching tv right now wendy
williams she's telling her
so 46 of the people polled in this
gallup poll uh say the media is too
liberal uh 13 say it's too conservative
and 37 percent
say it's just about right like porridge
um yes does that i mean to any of those
numbers really what are they gonna say
like they're gonna be like no i don't
trust them they're shady you know
you always have your favorite sources
like you love anderson cooper so you
always have your do you have somebody
that you feel like when you're watching
them is a little more obvious
like cnn is in the middle because i i am
myself an independent like i have to
hear you know what the topic is
sometimes i'm conservative on things
sometimes i'm liberal on things it
depends on what it is although i do shy
more towards liberal but um yeah i think
but you have a person
like an actual person that you go all
right that guy seems samantha shocker of
course on the cnn yes yes yes on hln i
believe she's amazing yes dr drew yes um
but
no i don't have i don't i don't follow a
specific person per se i'd like to just
kind of and that goes to how i am in
politics i kind of like to see
i like to sprinkle it all hear it all
um you know judge all so to speak but um
i'm much more interested in you know
what's being said on on the talk about
uh about my favorite celebs i gotta be
honest i'm i'm a total gossip like love
that uh stuff
well that's why you gave a shot a shout
out the world was too they're working
too rough it's too rough i got it i got
to hear something else yeah yeah um but
no yeah like you said like it's
according to who this is happening like
what kind of agenda is this gonna like i
don't trust you're you're saying we
trust you i don't trust what you just
said you don't trust trusting you yeah
it's like i don't even trust that yeah
so i mean whatever it's one of those
silly things that i think is is funny
but i don't really pay much attention to
and i don't you know yeah well you
shouldn't trust the media blindly anyway
and that's why what we do here at the
young turks there's no corporate
influence and even though i do have
something in my ear it's just so i can
hear the audio of videos i don't have
someone barking instructions at me at
least right this second i assure you
that i don't but actually if i was going
to say one or two people that i do sort
of think are a little more honest in
media i think jake tapper on cnn is
pretty decent he always looks depressed
which i think is a sign of someone
trying to tell the truth he has these
like his fa he's very sort of got these
sort of lines in his face that imply
like i know i'm sort of stuck in this
thing and i like aaron burnett she's
cute okay and let's move on
all right let's talk about burger king
they have come out with slightly lower
calorie french fries and they even gave
them a witty name status fries that's
right their regular french fries are 340
calories a serving and these french
fries although they're fried in the same
frying oil they're only going to be 270
calories as you can see that's slightly
different than their regular french fry
because they are crinkled uh which is
very exciting and uh obviously causes
more mouth movement which then will burn
calories as your i know i made that part
up so just a little more info about the
fry itself uh they are actually going to
be fried in the exact same fryer that
the regular burger king fries are fried
in but this has to do with the batter
they are somehow making the batter less
caloric but you're still eating fried
stuff i guess this is good because you
know it helps you sort of make decent
choices when you go to these places but
these places aren't really about making
good choices right i have two opinions
on this the first one is anything that's
diet it's like people think oh diet
cookies i can have the box you know
versus like two just regular cookies or
whatever you know it's like oh i would
have ordinarily had a small fry and i'll
have too large because it's diet so why
not and they end up you know consuming
more calories than they would have to
begin with the other thing is
mock my woods this is going to be the
sketches shape-ups
situation of burger king because people
think oh great all i have to do is just
get the saddest fries and now we losing
weight no time i'm on my way to a bikini
body in a second it's like no you need
to calm down on the french fries all
together wait those sketchers shape ups
is that what they were called did they
did did anyone wear those did people
really think yeah yeah and they walked
around
yeah
they were like my ankle would turn and i
didn't lose weight and i didn't well
obviously you didn't like you can't sit
on your couch with the shoes on and
expect something to happen you know so i
feel like it's kind of in that category
of like oh you don't just lose weight
when you put the shoe on you have
actually yeah exactly like you know it's
it's it's look it's great that they're
going this direction i think it's
fantastic that fast food chains in the
last five to ten years have made a huge
huge effort to you know add fruit or add
salads or add you know great cool pc
done now that being said
um it's just like and by the way on a
side note kudos to the guy that came up
with satisfied i'm satisfied oh my gosh
let me just give that man like he
obviously is in a big chair right now
yeah um but yeah i really think it's
just
it's only 20 difference i think that
people unfortunately will will
be like you know what i'm gonna get the
satisfies and then two burgers yeah yeah
i'm gonna make up for that twenty
percent i really don't think it's gonna
but the bigger issue here is people
aren't reading between the lines because
when i was looking at this you know it
said that a rep for burger king um when
asked what it was that made it less it
actually is something that prevent that
they won't disclose that prevents the
oil from soaking in more right in the
batter i'm like what are they dipping it
in kitty litter before they put it in
there it's like an oil retardant like
you know i just don't understand and
it's like what is that gonna do you know
to your body it's like how splenda
causes add and this causes cancer
sweetener or whatever it's like what is
that going to do usually honestly
you know the the
full fat the full whatever is actually
more beneficial to your body in your
life and that actually goes that goes to
what you were saying about how people
then compensate by eating more because
even if you think about diet soda you're
getting no calories but you're putting
all this aspartame in your body and then
on top of that you probably drink two or
three sodas when you may have only drank
one
regular coke filled with all that and
the general portions of burger king are
bigger than mcdonald's so a small fry in
mcdonald's that's full fat actually has
less calories then is that true it is
true i did you're telling me
i'm reporting
this
oh yeah mcdonald's and i don't work for
mcdonald's uh
yeah so you're saying a small fry at
mcdonald's and a small
fry at burger king are not a saddest
fries small hat still has more calories
than a small
mcdonald's full fat fry i didn't even
know mcdonald's had small fries they do
they have i
anymore because the movie uh got them to
take away supersize scientists at mit
that's a massachusetts institute of
technology believe they have found the
gene which performs the role of memory
extinction they've started doing this in
mice and they can basically isolate your
bad memories that's where this is all
going uh this is sort of like the movie
eternal sunshine for the spotless mind
and this is where the future is heading
they'll be able to erase our bad
memories but don't our bad memories sort
of add up to the whole human experience
and where will this lead us and i'm
opening that wide open question
i don't like it one bit
i do not like this you are shaking your
head i'm shaking this is this is
tampering with the human experience too
much i mean this is like the beginning
stages of number one
what if you know somebody's having an
off day and they slip a little bit on
whatever they're trying to you know
erase or whatever and something else
tradition or whatever i don't know the
exact technique that they're using but
i'm saying like it how close are we
talking here how can you pinpoint things
and also you know
there's not a way that you can say that
one experience is just completely
eliminated without affecting emotional
responses psychological responses you
know everything it's like a domino
effect so this is going to completely
affect your psyche and i just don't
trust that you know other aspects aren't
going to be removed and other aspects
aren't going to be added and and i would
like to say also that in reading the
story about the mice that were affected
yes i'm going to give somebody to say
you know we haven't interviewed these
mice first hand who's to say that those
mice that were
once scared about going in the cage and
then not scared what if actually what
they're doing in their brain and they
don't know it yet is they're adding some
type of like gangsta gene where instead
it's not that they've forgotten it's
just that they're like yeah
[ __ ] cage i'm here and i'm not
afraid so what's up you know you never
know so what if you tamper and all of a
sudden you just got a whole lot of
hardcore [ __ ] out there well
that being said i should probably
explain the study a little bit
so they used mice and they gave them a
mild electric shock when they entered a
certain cage and then when they altered
the tet one gene in half the mice they
no longer remembered the traumatic
experience so obviously this is a long
way from getting to where it can be used
for humans and where they could actually
select the specific memory and is this
really a gangster gene and god only
knows what they're doing but don't you
think the human experience if you we've
all had bad experiences in our lives if
you were able to go back and
erase something that happened to you
when you were eight that maybe was bad
don't you think it could cause a
cascading effect you know in the way
that you created your personality and
who you are i am with you i think that
it's disastrous i think that mistakes is
how you succeed through mistakes how
many times you've fallen how many times
you get up all that good stuff
and i believe the only risks that you
regret are the ones you didn't take in
life you know so
i don't know about gangstas that's a
little bit that's how much might be
gangsters i mean who knows they're
amplifying the genes so it might be you
know it might be like bring it but um i
was sort of picturing the hamsters from
the kia commercial but a little more
badass
whether or not they're able to do this
it's they shouldn't be able to i really
don't it's it's huge like i said it's
human experience i think that there's
something to be said for who like who
you are today is based on you know
it's going to be like zombies like
people walking around not remembering
certain things like even if it was let's
say it's a perfect science let's say
they were able to nail exactly and
extract exactly what they want to and
not refer it's like what good comes of
that anyways like really you know like i
don't know because then you're like
weaker then it's like you're a weaker
and you're walking around with
rose-colored glasses like
that and then you forgot that you've
been robbed before and you're walking
down the street
with your gold chains and there's these
other gangsters yeah ones that have been
amplified that are like give me okay now
and it's like no
right and then you'll just get addicted
to having your memory erased man that's
going to be the next thing and then
where what alcohol sales go i would like
to know that as well i thought that's
the whole point of going to a bar is to
like you know forget and forget the
reality for a little so really this
could harm the economy because people
won't be going to bars to bury their
dreams and booze this i mean this is
very much also like the movie vanilla
sky
and memory uh but the total recall which
is my favorite science fiction movie
that they could then go ahead and
implant memories so if you can't afford
the the big vacation they can implant
the memory of the big vacation i mean is
this this is all going to uh sort of
matrix stuff where we're just going to
sit in a chair all day and have things
beamed into us and we're just the
battery right we're just the battery
yeah i think this is definitely playing
with fire yeah i think we should
anything that has to do with that sort
of cerebral yeah but is that also part
of the human experience that anything
that we develop through science we
always use you know what i mean pretty
much the only thing that was ever
developed that they stopped using was
the the beta
you know instead of the vhs like they
like we use everything like isn't that
part of it like even if this does really
alter how we live and for all the bad
reasons
that it's sort of part of evolution that
maybe will evolve into into something
else or am i getting a little too i know
i think we're getting like really
like well what if that is the human
experience if we've created it you know
an illusion you're not really we're not
here no yeah you could go you could go
crazy with that yeah i say keep your
memories good and bad it makes you who
you are
builds character
i don't know or just suck them out and
see what happens whoo crazy
now if i could have other people's
memories sucked out i would be okay with
that i just don't know if i want to have
mine suck on that note i want to thank
my guests vanessa gomez and whitney
mixter and i'm going to let you guys
pimp yourselves out vanessa talk to that
camera right over there hello all okay
so if you have any sort of inkling or
like for anything horror then you would
love my new show nightmare night cap it
premieres on dreadcentral.com which is a
huge horror website so i'm really
excited check it out it's like two
minutes and we review everything from
like horror films to
halloween conventions to monster palooza
scarole you name it check it out
dreadcentral.com
and whitney mixer i know you have
something big coming up that i'm
possibly coming up that i'm not going to
mention here at this very moment yes we
won't mention things but stay tuned you
can follow me at whitneymixterla on
twitter and on instagram whitneymixterla
on instagram and we have a fall line
coming out and caught thin justice.com
so stay tuned for big things there you
go all right well we're going to go get
some uh satisfies and then get our
memory wiped and then do it all again
until we're fat bucks all right guys
thanks oh and subscribe it's right down
there click it forget about it okay
there you go thanks